do you think that the people who are
looking for you know these alternative
coins or kind of you know improvements
to Bitcoin how much of it is human greed
because I think there's gonna be
appreciation of price versus they're
actually being thoughtful as to you know
this is going to be better than Bitcoin
and I truly believe that and would hold
it for five years yeah right or more
yeah I think that and this is the reason
why on Twitter I make jokes about this
you know because Twitter on Twitter or
traders and investors are always talking
about alt season right when assault
season when all the all coin is gonna
come back you know and and what's that
shift I think that alt season will
always come back right I even with so
many of these all points down ninety
percent I think all season will come
back and the reason for that is because
crypto networks have such small
penetration into the kind of global
consciousness and human greed is so
immense that I I think it will come back
and we're you know about the greed
improvement thing I actually think that
most crypto projects are driven by greed
I truly believe that the cost of issuing
new tokens has fallen pretty
dramatically it's virtually zero now
requires white paper landing page
marketing team Roadshow advisor list
actual contract deployment so you can
you know add on another two hours for
that and you're sort of good to go right
that's what you need to raise money and
so I think that that mentality in
reality has reflected in and in a lot of
greed that we've seen from projects I
think that there are some you know
people who in the world who have made
efforts till I find the misguided
I think metallic is a great example of
this originally vitalik tried to bring
turing completeness to bitcoin there's a
number of reasons why the community sort
of pushed back against it you know all
of which in hindsight look like great
reasons you know and then Vitalik went
and started a separate project you know
similar things happened with the release
of Manero or sea cash
I think that other projects have some
novelty to them but for the most part
especially is you get into the long tail
of you know say lending projects right
there's five different crypto projects
that are all working on some sort of
lending token I think where you get into
that it's much more grounded in sort of
greed on the part of teams or you know
it's an existing team that's launching a
crypto project you know we're really
it's a play for non-dilutive financing
because that's what all token raises are
right you know there's no corporate
rights there's no you know Parata
liquidity rights you know there's
there's really no rights of any kind
right and so I I think a lot of that is
is short-termism I think a lot of it
it's great driven there are a few sort
of brave projects out there that are
vesting tokens right which is a
innovation the us technology investor
market has come up with decades ago
there are some teams vesting tokens over
very long periods of time six or eight
years which I find to be brave but
something I would be terrified of as a
founder and so I I do think it's mostly
mostly greed driven and over the long
term
ie I think it's great right it's
bringing more interest to the space and
really all of these or free research
projects for Bitcoin that's how I view
it you know whatever it is you know if
it if it works out long term it'll find
a way to get in if it's something that's
important and something people value